after the second and final day of
cross-examination of House Democrats and
White House lawyers in the US Senate a
significant moment in Donald Trump's
impeachment trial Tennessee Republican
Lamar Alexander announced ahead of
Friday's scheduled for our debate that
he would not vote for the introduction
of more witnesses and documents his
argument is that there's no need for
more evidence to show that President
Trump withheld aid to pressure the
Ukrainian government to investigate
former Vice President Joe Biden and his
son hunter he did but while that was
inappropriate doing so did not rise to
the level of a high crime and
misdemeanor and the removal of the
president from office Alexander also
said in a statement that the whole
impeachment process had been quote
shallow horrid and wholly partisan with
the potential to rip the country apart a
major argument of trumps lawyers were in
an election year there are some in this
room that are days away from the Iowa
caucuses taking place
so we're discussing the possible
impeachment and removal of the President
of the United States not only during
election season in the heart of the
election season and I think that this
does a disservice to the American people
the Democrats then did not convince
Alexander that by definition a trial
should have witnesses it is certainly in
their interest and the president's
interest that we have a fair trial a
trial without truth without key evidence
without witnesses and documents would
render the president's acquittal
meaningless as things stand that means
the Democrats are very unlikely to get
the 51 votes they need to call for
witnesses the most they could hope for
is a draw of 54 and 58 gainst witnesses
and documents unless there's a major
surprise and the expectation is a draw
would mean the motion for new evidence
will be judged to have failed
Alexander's decision makes it very
likely that the president will be
acquitted after what's expected to be
many hours of debate on Friday the White
House's go they're off an acquittal
before Donald Trump delivers his State
of the Union address next Tuesday
appears to have all but been achieved
cher Burton C al Jazeera Washington